bonsoir et bienvenue à tous on commence
donc avec la fin d'une chape de plomb
pendant des années les autorités
françaises sont restées silencieuses
face aux demandes des vétérans qui ont
participé aux essais nucléaires leur
taux de cancers seraient deux fois plus
élevés que la moyenne
et bien aujourd'hui le gouvernement
annonce un projet de loi les victimes
seront reconnus et indemniser jérôme
berling emmanuelle bec
vous vivez dans le blockhaus de la mise
à feu la minute solennelle de la
première explosion atomique française la
fin de 50 années d'hypocrisie
aujourd'hui l'armée admis que les essais
nucléaires ont pu provoquer des maladies
jusqu'à présent il fallait aller en
justice pour le faire reconnaître
désormais si la loi est votée
l'indemnisation deviendra un principe
toute personne malade si steam en ayant
souffert d'un niveau d'exposition à
partir d'un certain seuil aura un droit
à l'indemnisation
la france a procédé à 210 essais
nucléaires
cent mille personnes y ont participé de
près ou de loin
aujourd'hui 132 plaintes sont devant la
justice
est ce la fin des procédures les
associations attendent de voir ce qui
les inquiète
le ministère parle encore de seuils de
contamination je connais vos repas
monsieur - c'est la contamination dont
viennent parler les millions de petites
particules qui pendant des semaines on
voler autour de nous et que nous avons
inhalé par les voies digestives et par
les voies respiratoires
enfin l'état se réserve des possibilités
de refus d'indemniser notamment si les
maladies invoquées sont liées au tabac
ou à l'alcool